big fan of this man's work uh not just
because we were in a movie together back
in the day and by in a movie together i
mean the same credits that rolled
um he is in our kind of people uh on fox
you can catch a new episode tonight at
nine eastern time new episodes air all
tuesdays on fox at 9 00 pm eastern
morris chestnut back here on the rich
eisen show how you been morris
i've been great rich you know that that
that sound bite sounded a lot like our
conversation that you did but the advice
you gave me the other day so i want to
say thank you and that everybody here
would you would you have said well it
was you know you reached out to me uh on
the set of lil bow wow i mean with a
little about wow you reached out to me
on the set of uh
uh
like mike back in the day
and uh i told you to take care of your
mentals and chicken and now look at you
you know exactly you know what i'm
saying so i was like wow you know how
you come full circle now the next day
i'm on your show martial into saying the
same thing so you gave him that same
advice clearly
clearly um how you doing what's going on
in your world man i'm good how are you
doing i'm hanging in there just so much
to talk about in the sports world the
nfl week
week four just finished up and the nba
is about to start up ben simmons says
he's not playing in philadelphia we're
all wondering about that what about
what's going on with the kyrie i wonder
what's hitting you any any news sports
headline hitting you
my eagles didn't fare too well this uh
this past weekend you know i'm a huge
eagles fan so they didn't fare too well
but i'm looking forward to my dodgers
and my lakers so my dodgers play a
playoff game tomorrow i'm looking
forward to that and then my lakers will
be playing you know of course they're
going to be playing playoff games and
finals games uh later on in 2022 very
early in 2022 okay i'm excited about
that no on every dodger fan i know
morris is not happy about winning a
billion games and then having to play
just a one game playoff with the hottest
team in baseball from mid-august to the
current moment in the cardinals not
happy about that at all you know you
know what it's it's tough you know it is
tough but hey i mean we didn't win the
division that the giants were the giants
were just unbelievable i mean every time
i turn around they were winning and we
couldn't catch them and now we're in
this position and hey if we have the
best players we have a great pitcher
taking them out in scherzer and great
talent and bets and and turner and the
other turner i mean hey we just have to
put our best foot forward and go handle
our business so you're a dodger fan
because
you're from the area
yeah born and raised in los angeles
that's what i thought okay and then
you're uh
a laker fan because of that too
yeah where do the eagles crack the code
here morris where did we go crack the
code i mean many many many years ago
they were one of the last nfl football
teams to wear like the college cutoff
jerseys you know and i used to like
wilbur montgomery and harold carmichael
and wilbur montgomery when he used to
wear the kind of same kind of cleats
that i had when i was in uh playing pop
warner with that they're like this black
soul and they were white with this black
soul with the cut off jerseys and i was
just i've just been a fan since and then
when they got randall cunningham and i
just i just love the team since well i
just saw harold carmichael he got in the
hall of fame finally and he looks like
he could get he could point a couple
catches right now still to me well i
think we could use them
we do have some young talent we do have
some young calendars out there that's
finding their way but i think we could
use another receiver a tall
receiver who can go out there and you
know be a possession type of guy so they
should suit him up okay and uh and then
the lakers i mean uh who who else can
they get to play for him who else do you
think i mean we got uh
we got lebron we got anthony davis now
russ russ um carmelo right we got
carmelo uh why not him is there a fifth
you want i mean since it's a fantasy
league pretty much
being put together
i know it's going to be tough for the
league to accept um you know lebron's
going to get another ring he's going to
get a second and then russ is going to
get his first you know and then carmelo
is going to get his first it's going to
be tough but hey that's just what it is
i mean did you ask new jersey that i
mean how many people do they want to
bring it i got you um yes i have not
asked them that um but uh what do you
say to the the there are those who might
say that that ring that anthony davis
has was is a is like a bubble ring it's
a it's a ring and a bubble like that
wasn't like you know say the eighty two
i would well
my my my answer to that is i mean why is
it any different than what any other
team had to face i mean we all we all
had to go through the same thing you
know it's not like the lakers weren't in
the bubble and then they came in like
the last minute though they were in the
bubble just like everybody else we were
just stronger mentally i like it okay
very good so you got things going on
well your things are good you know
so you're you're not uh latching on to
any of the
the new uh los angeles teams in football
with the new beautiful stadium just up
the road here have you uh yeah no
thoughts you're still sticking with the
eagles pretty much well see i'm
i'm a huge football fan i'm a football
loser because all i do on sundays is
just watch all of the games so i'm a
huge football fan um i like what san
diego's doing uh herbert looks great um
you know i love what the rams are doing
even though they lost this past weekend
i you know i like this style of play and
of course deshawn jackson the former
eagle is over there yes
you know
when they throw the ball to him so you
know i'm watching it so far i haven't
been there yet have you been there i
hear something i have it's unbelievable
you got to do it there's unbelievable
sometimes yeah you might have to leave
you know uh now for the next game but um
you know i did hear that
um but it is it is incredible and just
to correct you morris uh you
watching football all day
doesn't make you a football loser quite
the contrary makes you a football winner
you're winning okay you're winning okay
well you have the well everything's
about perspective so you're the glass
half i mean i like that you're right i'm
a football winner you're a winner i mean
the fact that you get to do something
like that and there's nobody anybody
saying get get off the couch i mean like
that's a win that's a w that's one in
the comments you hang that banner in the
okay
rafters
good because i'm on that couch
all day when i'm in l.a from 10 o'clock
to you know eight nine o'clock i'm just
watching all of the games and
fortunately you know my wife is you know
i i do everything else for her during
the week and on the weekend so so i get
i'm i'm awarded
and rewarded with sundance to where she
love it leaves me out the honey dude
morris chestnut here on the rich eisen
show so there you don't shoot our kind
of people on sundays there's no sunday
shot shoots on on no show no no i
actually had it in the contract where i
can't work on sunday night uh though
unfortunately we don't we don't uh we
don't shoot on sundays that's great uh
monday through friday okay cool so tell
me about the show what what you like
about it and what uh what you appreciate
and what people should watch it for yeah
it's a very fun show our kind of people
it's basically it's a it's a it's a fun
salacious uh kind of soap opera type of
nighttime soap opera show where we
reveal a lot of sex a lot of secrets and
a lot of scandal
um and working with a great cast and uh
we're having a great time having a great
time and that's on uh tonight nine
eastern time on fox new episodes airing
tuesday 9pm eastern
on fox um what's what's the what's the
thing that you saw on a script you're
like i can't believe they're making me
do this
well
it was the opportunity to work with uh
lee daniels you know i've had a great
relationship with fox you know i'm still
on one of their other shows residents
i've done all the the doctor shows i've
done the cop shows and this was like
this is like my first time the nighttime
soap opera we have a lot of you know a
lot of good-looking women wearing very
little clothes so i said okay sign me up
just you know just to be an actor on
here of course and um and it was a great
script i loved the network and i said
hey you know and lee daniels and i karen
just our show runner and i just had to
be a part of it okay um before i let you
go morris every now and then we we like
to play certainly with our um celebrity
guests right here on the rich eyes and
show mercedes-benz vans phone line um we
like to play a game called uh celebrity
true or false where we read stuff from
your wikipedia or your imdb page to see
if it's actually true or it's not just
sure to think okay can we hit that
please they got some production value
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
okay uh first one for you morris chess
not true or false uh one of your first
roles of your career is you were the
prison bus guard on the bus that went uh
kaboom in the fugitive is that true or
false
uh that is false that is false i was not
in the fugitive i would have loved to
work with harrison ford and but no i was
not in the future you are not okay no
you got to call wikipedia man we got to
get that off it says you were the prison
bus guard in the fugitive in 1993 that
is not true
that is not accurate that is not
actually oh gosh all right how about
that then here's this one uh in 1998 you
won the madden bowl video game
competition in 1998 is that true or
false morris that is true um we went
down to san diego they had a mad bowl
where i was playing against other uh
other celebrities and athletes and i won
the madden bowl and i was on i was on
the game the very next year okay so
uh who did you beat in the madden bowl
competition
you know the competition was so easy i
don't even remember i always do it you
know the players at that time they
couldn't play it it was easy yeah it was
easy so i don't remember i just remember
holding up the trophy and then i was
featured on the game the very next year
holding up who was your who was your pl
who was your team in that line i played
with the eagles that's like oh you know
i take that back no i think at that
point no i take that back that year i
played with the raiders and won the
championship with the raiders okay i
always played with the eagles but for
the championship i played with the
raiders you you played with the raiders
okay
true or false you've been in three
stephen seagal movies morris chestnut is
that true or false
uh i've been in two stephen stephen
cigar movies so that's just they're
close okay
well are you are you aware that every
stephen seagal movie with the exception
of of only a handful are just three
words in the title are you aware of that
no i wasn't yes
it was interesting like half past dead
prince of pistols under siege two which
is i guess one of those uh out for
justice all that sort of stuff it's only
it's all three words every single time i
didn't i didn't realize that i did i
didn't realize that okay but uh there
you go because you know because stephen
he would change the script so much i
mean there were only three words that
did you beat him up at any point in time
no no it was never that i would have
never been able to do that i mean he was
very good at what he did and he was you
know he was beating up a lot of stunt
guys but um
but no i didn't know i didn't beat him
okay and last one for you you thought
like mike was going to be a total bust
until you found out that rich eisen was
playing himself in a cameo role is that
true or false
very true very true as a matter of fact
i almost didn't sign on until i knew
rich eisen was gonna of course
i made it real
i brought the real i brought the reel to
my role you know i brought it to my room
exactly did you exactly did did you have
to like um
take any lessons or anything like that
to get in shape or get your shot down to
make it look like you were an actual nba
player morris you know the interesting
thing about that is
yes so at the time when i got the role i
was like okay cool i'm going to be able
to go and practice and reggie theis was
the uh was one of the technical advisors
gets trained and played with reggie
theaters and i can get my game because
i'm a weekend warrior and i'm getting my
game right and then i'm going to do this
and i'm do that and
sure enough when it came time to do it
and playing against guys who had been
because a lot of those extras used to
play some more overseas and all that and
uh when i was out on the court with them
um i i should not have been because
they were just so much better than i was
and there was nothing there was no
really working on my game so excited
about it originally but no my game did
not improve as a result of that
but then you put on the magic shoes and
everything worked out right i mean the
jordan shoes you just put them on laced
them up and then you were better than
reggie theaters well that was bow had
the shoes so bow had the spout
i know but you you could have had them
like you could have said to wardrobe
just give me the shoes give me some
others i should i should have had them
make a size for me and i and i i could
have done that but yeah it didn't work
out for me and and i'm telling you i was
really excited when when they were like
okay you'll be like mike and you know
reggie is going to train you one on one
and stevie thompson i was like okay cool
i can learn from these guys that no it
didn't it it just didn't work out that
wouldn't work out well everything has
worked out otherwise for you uh our kind
of people on fox tuesdays not eastern
including tonight morris thanks for the
time man a great chat with you hey
appreciate thanks for having me get
ready i'll be back yeah anytime at
morris underscore chestnut on twitter
and at morris chestnut official on
instagram hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here